[موسيقى]
كما ترون خلفنا درب ابا القد التاريخي
الاثري يخترق صفحه جبل طويق بخط مستقيم
الذين اختاروه ونحتوه ونجروا وقصوا الجبل
ليس فقط رصفا وبناء جدران انما قص للصخر
بطريقه مستقيم شرقا الى حجر اليمامه عبر
وادي نمار والطرق الاخرى
[موسيقى]
لكن ما الذي يهمنا يهمنا ان هناك تنظيم
لصعود القوافل فيها اشخاص في الاعلى وفي
الاسفل لان اذا اتت قافله من الرياض من
حجر اليمامه قديما لابد ان تتوقف القافله
اللي تحت واذا صعدت قافله لابد ان تتوقف
القافله النازله ففي غرف الان ظاهر اعلاها
في الاسفل هذه يدل انه في ناس يقيمون في
هذا المكان
[موسيقى]
في باحثين اجتهدوا وقالوا انه عمل في
العصر الاسلامي وهذا ليس صحيح لانه لم
يثبت ان الدوله العصر الخلفاء الراشدين او
الدوله الامويه شقت طريق في هذا الجبل
الشاهر جبل طويق باتجاه الرياض حجر
اليمامه طوله كيلو متر واحد هذا هذا اقيم
في وقت في استقرار ووقت خصب ووقت قوه
اقتصاديه ومعروف ان طسم وجديس اللي
استقروا في اليمامه كانوا امه عمرانيه
وفي دليل اخر على قدمه هو المدفن مدفن
دائري ذو ذيل في اعلى الجبل
[موسيقى]